mais il faut arrêter de déconner les
responsabilités que tout le monde les
prenne
Nordine vous avez 30 ans vous êtes né
dans bidonville de Nanterre de famille
de 9 enfants
qu'est-ce que vous avez gardé vous du
comme souvenir de votre enfant pour ma
part j'ai grandi en bas âge
au bidonville de Nanterre après on était
dans un F2
à 11 il faut pas oublier les parents
après quelques temps après on a déménagé
en cité transit à Nanterre ainsi que
Gutenberg en principe ça devait durer
trois ans à l'époque il y avait eu une
corde
de journaliste qui était venu avec le
Premier ministre de l'époque c'était
Chaban-Delmas pour se féliciter de la
construction de cette cité de cette
misère des fois il y avait des conflits
avec les gens qui habitaient dans les
bâtiments à côté il y avait des bagarres
avec leurs enfants tout ça il y avait
des histoires qui se produisent
et
on est venu par la force des choses
parce qu'on fréquentait les mêmes écoles
plus ou moins amis je dis plus ou moins
parce que des fois ça allait des fois ça
allait pas parce qu'il y avait des gens
dans ces cité embêtant qui avait des
attitudes quand il nous voyaient arriver
dans leur cité il nous on avait on était
des mots et il nous surveillait ils
avaient
des idées préconçues dans la tête et ça
j'ai pu ressentir pendant toute la
période juste avant mon adolescence
quand il fallait obliger être obligé de
manquer l'école pour accompagner le père
ou la mère à la sécurité sociale pour
remplir un papier que les gens qui
étaient fonctionnaires à la sécu pouvait
remplir je pense à ça ça m'ennuyait ça
m'ennuyait ça veut dire qu'on était
obligé de soutenir tout le temps nos
parents moi je bougeais à l'époque à
l'école comme délégué de classe parce
que je trouvais que certains délégués de
classe n'étaient pas là pour représenter
les élèves mais était plutôt là pour
pour dire le respect des sur la vie quoi
comment ils entendent comment quelqu'un
qui a fait trois ans de cap
en fin d'année on veut l'expulser alors
qu'il arrive à son examen c'est plein de
choses comme ça c'était Xavier qui est
là façon moi j'étais pas très grand
j'arrivais dans une école vous aviez des
mecs qui étaient comment les appelait
les BTS
les mecs barbus tout costaud qui était
là
brevets techniciens supérieures alors
nous on avait notre rangée juste à côté
d'eux et nous on était là ça veut dire
que les gens qui étaient musulmans qui
mangeaient pas de porc en l'occurrence
on se mettait à côté il y a eu des
accrochages il y a eu des problèmes avec
le temps parce que on a voulu nous faire
en plus
de la voir qu'on nous a fait suivre qui
était pas celle qu'on avait accepté mais
dans celle dans laquelle on nous avait
mis parce que au préalable j'étais en 5e
et 6e transition
ça veut dire qu'on a jugé je sais pas je
devais avoir 10 ans 11 ans que j'étais
pas capable de pouvoir suivre des études
donc on vous a mis sur un on vous a
sorti du circuit traditionnel
et à partir de là on nous on vous met
dans une classe comme ça vous apprenez à
planter des clous à faire des longues
récrées on vous apprend rien on vous
apprend pas à faire des maths modernes
ou je sais pas de l'histoire ou
apprendre
j'étais en 3e année de CAP et que même
dans ma dernière année il y en a une que
j'ai redoublé j'ai été dans une école où
il y a un professeur qui m'a traité un
jour de marchand de tapis alors là
à partir de ce jour-là j'ai dit celui
qui continuera à me parler comme ça qui
se permettra d'avoir des attitudes par
rapport à mon origine et ben il faudra
qu'il soit costaud faudra qu'il soit
fort et c'est tout doucement que après
je suis sorti de l'école j'ai travaillé
au marché je travaille au marché ouais
tout doucement après dans la cité je me
suis occupé des mondes sans regarder
l'aspect politique des choses en
essayant de de par exemple quand il y
avait quelques mots qui avaient envie
d'aller à la piscine de les accompagner
par l'intermédiaire d'un club de
prévention qui donnait la thune parce
que nous on pouvait les faire sortir
mais on n'avait pas l'argent on était
compétent mais on n'a pas la on avait
pas les moyens et moi ce que je nous
reproche à nous c'est de pas frapper
assez fort sur la table en disant voilà
on paye des impôts locaux on voudrait
que notre quartier
qu'on parle pas du couloir ça je m'en
fous moi je veux qu'on parle de la
Justice de la police et des rapports
dans le quartier c'est quoi l'avenir bah
l'avenir pour moi c'est d'espérer que
enfin
les jeunes des banlieues ont compris que
droites comme la gauche pour nous c'est
la même il y a un ami qui s'appelle
Bouzid qui disait avec la droite c'est
un four à 200 degrés avec la gauche
c'est un four à 42 degrés dans les deux
conditions on cuit et nous on n'a pas
envie de cuire alors voilà ça veut dire
que ça fait des années qu'on nous a
endormi aujourd'hui j'ai envie que les
petits frères les grands frères même lui
prennent conscience qu'on oui qu'on
qu'on peut plus rigoler on peut plus
s'amuser qu'il faut qu'on soit ferme ça
veut dire que être ferme c'est pas
forcément l'utilisation de la violence
être ferme ça veut dire occuper la place
publique je dis pas qu'avec descend en
banlieue mais il faut arrêter de
déconner les responsabilités que tout le
monde les prenne que les gens dans la
société et regarde les gens dans la de
la banlieue dans les yeux qu'ils
arrêtent de nous de nous prendre pour
désirer des irresponsables pour des gens
qui avaient envie que de détruire non on
a envie de construire on a envie de que
notre clarté il soit beau on a envie que
nos petits frères et puissent traîner
sans ramasser de 120 on a envie qui est
tout ça la drogue c'est pas c'est pas
propre dans le lieu non
mais je crois que que dans les banlieues
pour les pour les jeunes il y a il y a
un mal d'être un mal de vivre ils ont
ils n'ont pas de balises ils sont
rejetés aussi très souvent et
il se réfugie dans dans ce qui trouve
parce qu'ils ont pas de travail ils ont
pu à l'école ils traînent toute la
journée donc automatiquement ils font
n'importe quelle rencontre et c'est là
où justement les dealers mais je parle
pas du du petit dealer du dernier de du
Maillon je parle de de celui qui lui
n'en prend pas très souvent c'est
celui-là le plus dangereux et c'est cela
que j'arrive pas à choper je voulais un
peu prendre la parole pour situer un peu
sur l'ambiance qui est en ce moment
concernant
différents événements qui se sont
produites en banlieue ces derniers jours
ce qui s'est passé avant Vaulx-en-Velin
ces derniers temps c'est que les jeunes
ont une sentiment et
c'est un courrier qui me l'a confirmé
que on leur a laissé aucune chance ça
veut dire qu'on a tiré sur des jeunes
qui étaient en train de faire un vol de
voiture effectivement prendre une
voiture est-ce que pourquoi on a attendu
le moment où ils allaient démarrer avec
cette voiture on fait de la prévention
pour vol de voiture il y a pas de
condamnation à mort il y a pas de
condamnation et ça fait à plusieurs
reprises où il y a des jeunes qui
meurent de mort violente ou on commence
à parler de dealer c'est devenu une mode
s'il y a un problème de drogue
effectivement qu'on en parle mais nous
de la manière dont on en parle on dit il
faut casser le dealer qui vient dans ton
quartier ou celui qui va en bas de chez
toi c'est pas ton ami c'est pas ton
frère il faut le marave il faut lui
régler son compte il y a pas d'histoire
de copains amis non il y a pas il y a de
la distance tu vends de la mort et ben
je regrette t'as pas à être en bas de
chez moi t'as pas être dans mon quartier
c'est un rapport dur parce que la drogue
c'est un rapport violent moi je crois
qu'il y a un passif et sur ce passif il
faut en parler quoi il faut parler des
choses qui sont passées notamment quand
il y a des jeunes qui sont victimes de
la violence de la vie dans ces cités là
il faut avoir une attitude de grand
frère une attitude de grand frère ça
veut dire qu'il y a des choses qu'on
fait pas si on veut dire aux jeunes dans
les banlieues il faut respecter ça il
faut faire ça il faut à mon avis en plus
de l'économie
parler des problèmes de justice on peut
pas ignorer ces problèmes là on peut pas
ignorer ses problèmes de police quand tu
quelqu'un lui a retiré la vie
on lui a retiré la vie avec une balle
alors que il avait 17 ans il avait 18
ans il avait 14 ans elle avait 14 ans il
a pris un mois
un mois et on pense que dans la banlieue
il y a pas de mémoire on a tous une
mémoire collective on a la même mémoire
quand on parle de ça on parle surtout
d'injustice on parle de ces trucs là il
faut pas croire qu'un jeune de 14 ans
vous allez l'endormir vous pouvez plus
l'endormir comme il y a quelques années
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]